Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich ein
altbewährter Stelle
aber ich
wundere mich du bist zurück in Hamburg
ich bin ich bin zurück ja du warst auf
Fernreise weil ja ich war wirklich viel
unterwegs in den letzten Wochen und
deswegen habe ich oft an Dich gedacht
und dachte ey jetzt einmal für einen
kurzen Moment bei Richard in der
kriminade das wäre schön das heißt das
klingt so als wären die die Reisen nicht
nur entspannend gewesen nee es war es
war wahnsinnig interessant aber es war
nee es war nicht ruhig und entspannt mit
Ruhe und Entspannung hatte deswegen viel
zu tun ich habe nur mitgekriegt dass du
im Reich der gagarosen warst du sprichst
es korrekt aber wusste ich vorher nicht
dass es gagarosen gibt ich hätte die
irgendwie so eher so in den Bereich von
Michael Ende einsortiert Geschichte oder
so
als die die einem die Zeit stehen oder
irgend sowas es gibt wirklich
aus es gibt gagaosen und nicht gagausen
ja wie man so lesen würde ich wir waren
in Moldau oder ein Moldawien unterwegs
und das war zwar wahnsinnig faszinierend
allein die Anreise dahin zu kommen und
gaga-usien ja wie es offiziell heißt ist
so eine so eine kleine autonome Provinz
mitten in Moldau Moldau ist ja ohnehin
ein sehr kleines Land zweieinhalb
Millionen Einwohner
also Bayern könnte sozusagen zwei
Staaten aus ich mache hier so ja
doppelmoldau genau
und Söder wird dann aber beides
übernehmen natürlich weil er ja Franke
ist und in München ja auch schon am
Start ist also wirklich ich finde das
mindestens
das finde ich auch nee und wir wollten
dahin ich war dort mit Sieg kongolf
unterwegs mit der ich auch die Amerika
und den Russland Film gemacht habe und
England Film und so weiter und Silke ist
ja ich schätze die so als Autorin weil
die einfach immer so ein ganz anderen
Blick noch mal so auf die Dinge hat und
wir haben uns vor einiger Zeit schon
verabredet um uns Moldau mal genauer
anzuschauen wusste eigentlich nicht viel
über Molde aber ich wollte da immer mal
hin ist das ärmste Land Europas und das
das spürst du wenn da wenn du da anreist
eine allein die Anreise wir sind über
Warschau und dann nach von Warschau nach
kishingau geflogen dass die Hauptstadt
von Moldawien und dann landest du auf
diesem sehr kleinen Flughafen dann
fliegst der ewig lang fliegst du über so
so ja so hügelige Landschaft der kriegst
dann so ein Gefühl dafür je weiter es
dann nach Osten geht was eigentlich so
diese mit dieser Kornkammer Europas
gemeint war ja du siehst dann diese
diese endlosen Felder alles sehr
landwirtschaftlich geprägt irgendwie
auch unheimlich schönes wie eine
Zeitreise ja wie wie zurück in die 70er
80er Jahre und dann landest du auf
diesem kleinen Flughafen auch
spektakulär weil wir flogen an und
Wetter bester Sonnenschein alles
wunderbar und kurz bevor wir landen
startet der Pilot durch keiner weiß
warum es wurde aber auch nie erklärt
wurde auch nie gesagt was da genau
passiert ist wir treten einfach nochmal
so einen einen schönen Zettel um
kischchenau und irgendwann meldete sich
der Pilot und sagte der ist noch Problem
ja about to land in der fuminits dachte
okay wunderbar
so leicht panisch und wir landeten dann
auch waren weit und breit keine anderen
Flugzeuge zu sehen und dann erlebst du
halt das was du immer lebst wenn du in
Länder kommst wo die Dinge dann sehr
einfach sind wo viele arme Leute sind du
kommst dann raus und dann stehen da
diese ganzen Männer und gucken dich an
mit ihren großen Augen und hoffen dass
sie dir die nächste Taxifahrt verkaufen
können da weißt du dann schon immer
okay dass das erlebst du so wenn du wenn
du in in Ländern des Südens irgendwo
auch in Afrika zum Beispiel unterwegs
bist da weißt du
ja genau und und hoffen darauf dass die
nächste Taxifahrt ihre ist so und dann
fährst du da rein in diese Stadt kisinau
da gibt es ein paar moderne westliche
Hotels und war ich überrascht davon wie
wie wie wie wie belebt das alles so ist
aber etwas fällt dir auf und das habe
ich erst im Laufe der Reise wirklich
verstanden
die Städte sind leise
das ist ruhig das ist nicht ein wenig
Verkehr genau es ist wenig Verkehr es
sind vergleichsweise wenig Menschen
unterwegs
und du merkst dann irgendwann das ist
demografischer Faktor das ist Demografie
die bluten aus du du bist dann auf dem
Markt unterwegs und dann triffst du sehr
viele alte Leute sehr viele Rentner die
dort auf dem Markt einkaufen
Gemüsegarten Europas habe ich gerade
gesagt ja
wunderschön was ist da alles so gibt
also alles was die Natur so hergibt dann
fängst du mal an mit den Leuten zu
sprechen in diesem in dieser in dieser
Markthalle und dann fallen dir zwei
Dinge auf das erste ist die Leute reisen
teilweise von weit her an und versuchen
irgendwie ihre kleine kargerente ein
bisschen aufzubessern Rentner Leben von
hundert Euro im Monat
und und kommen dann vom Land weit her
was sie selber irgendwie so anbauen und
versuchen das dort irgendwie ein
bisschen unter die Leute zu bringen das
andere Preise damit man diese 100 Euro
in einem Verhältnis setzen kann also was
die Preise genau angeht natürlich sind
die niedriger aber die Inflation ist
gigantisch die haben im Moment so
kämpfen mit 30 32 33% Inflation wo kommt
das her also es ist Wirtschaft geht so
schlecht und so viel Geld gedruckt
Wirtschaft und und der abgedrehte gasan
aus Russland die die Russen die haben
ihre gesamte Gas aus Russland gekriegt
ne richtig richtig genau und die und die
machen den richtig Druck da wird einfach
Gas Energie wird als Waffe angesetzt da
musste dann die Regierung noch
eingreifen da die EU mitgeholfen ja
das kommt dann aus dem Westen jetzt
mittlerweile auch auch die die
Stromversorgung die die wurde schon zum
Teil ähnlich wie in der Ukraine auch vor
dem Krieg bereits umgestellt die haben
das irgendwie kommen sehen
nur mit LKWs dahin transportieren
Gasflaschen ja ist richtig aber das gibt
es gibt zum Beispiel einen Hafen im im
Süden von Moldawien der mittlerweile die
Funktion im Wesentlichen des Hafens von
Odessa und deshalb liegt ja wenn du dort
unterwegs bist liegt keine 150 km
entfernt da waren wir auch und der Hafen
von Odessa da kommst du nicht mehr rein
der ist ja von den Russen irgendwann
bombardiert worden und da findet im
Grunde nichts mehr statt und ist jetzt
alles ausgewichen auf diesem einen Hafen
in in Moldawien also an dem Punkt
profitiert Moldawien dann auch wenn du
so willst von diesem Krieg und du siehst
Tag und Nacht diese gigantischen LKW
Kolonnen die eben in die Ukraine rein
und wieder rausfahren die ganze Straße
ist eine einzige LKW-Kolonne und dann
kriegst du mal ein Gefühl dafür was es
bedeutet wenn wenn wenn wenn man so ein
Krieg anzettelt wenn man einfach hingeht
und
geübte Prozess klar
Verkehr jetzt Transport kann mir die die
Nachricht die Ukraine hat ein Einbruch
beim Bruttoinlandsprodukt um 30 Prozent
richtig nein
und das muss man sich ja nur mal Spaß
ist aber vorstellen also reicht das Land
wie Deutschland hätte ein
Wirtschaftseinbruch von einem Drittel
und dann überlegen was das für so ein
armes Land wie die Ukraine bedeutet
richtig richtig und auch für ein Land
wie Moldawien z.B bedeutet ja wenn du
plötzlich explodierende Energiepreise
hast und auf die Art und Weise wird dann
eben Politik gemacht und was ihm das
wollte ich gerade noch erzählen du bist
auf diesem Markt und es war irgendwie
schön das war wie so eine Zeitreise du
redest damit zur alten Bäuerinnen die
von weit her angereist kommen und gab
eines Szene da habe ich eine eine alte
Frau 82 83 ich habe die dann
fotografiert und mitten im Gespräch fing
sie plötzlich an zu weinen und ich habe
sie dann gefragt warum sie weint und das
war so es hat mich wirklich angefasst
weil sie war von dieser Aufmerksamkeit
irgendwie überwältigt erst hat sie
berührt dass da Leute für sie
interessiert hast das gesetzliche
Fernsehen
das Fernsehen war ja egal aber einfach
die Frage zu stellen wie geht es dir
eigentlich was ist eigentlich dein Leben
erzähl doch mal deine Geschichte und ich
erlebe das oft gerade in so gebeutelten
Ländern wenn du wenn du mit Menschen ins
Gespräch kommst die wirklich am am
unteren Ende der Gesellschaft irgendwie
durchkommen müssen die die sind es nicht
mehr gewohnt dass man sich für sie
großartig interessiert und wenn du mit
den plötzlich sprichst dann dann löst
das manchmal bei dem was aus das war
nicht das erste Mal dass ich das erlebt
habe das hat mich wirklich gepackt und
das zweite was interessant ist ist über
diesen Markt liegt so eine wie soll ich
dir das beschreiben so eine Melanie so
eine Traurigkeit
und ich habe das irgendwie versucht zu
greifen und dachte woher kommt das was
ist das Thema bist du dann merkst diese
Traurigkeit hat einen ganz konkreten
Grund egal welche Frau die dort steht
und in der Regel sind es Frauen du
fragst sagst hast du Kinder ja ich habe
Kinder zwei oder drei wo sind diese
Kinder die Antwort wird immer sein in
Frankreich in Deutschland in England in
Portugal in Italien viele in Italien
weil rumänisch und Italienisch sind sich
vergleichsweise ähnlich und ähnliche
sprachmematische Sprache genau das heißt
ich konnte zum Teil auch ein bisschen
verstehen was da so gesprochen wurde
gibt Wörter die exakt identisch sind im
italienischen
das heißt da gibt es diesen
Abschiedsschmerz diese diese Kinder sind
alle weg ja die die die suchen ihr Glück
auf Baustellen in Westeuropa in der
Gastronomie in Westeuropa einfach so
ähnlich sein wie Ende der 60er Anfang
der 70er Jahre italienischen Süden ja
die die ganzen Gastarbeiter damals alle
alle weg waren und die Kinder alle
richtig waren genau und die Gesellschaft
nur die die die die die die die Armen
und vor allen Dingen die alten die
zurück bleiben und wann das hat das
Gefühl einer in einer sterbenden Kultur
wichtig und das sind genau das ist auch
das Gefühl und es war für mich
wahnsinnig interessant das mal von der
anderen Seite noch mal so bewusst
wahrzunehmen wir diskutieren ja ganz
viel über die Frage Migration was machen
wir bloß mit all den Menschen die
irgendwie in dieses Land in dieses
Deutschland drängen aber das mal von der
anderen Seite zu sehen noch mal zu
gucken was macht das eigentlich mit
denen das war hoch interessant und du
triffst also niemanden nicht
einen Vater eine Mutter die nicht diesen
diesen Abschiedsschmerz hat ja wann
siehst du dein Sohn wieder wann siehst
du deine Tochter wieder wie geht es denn
eigentlich und so weiter das war sehr
interessant ich habe einen jungen Mann
der kann zwar so Teenies liefen deinen
Kisch hinauf dann im Zentrum kam so auf
uns zu und sahen dass ich fotografiert
habe und das war so ein nassforscher
junger Typ und und er suchte so das
Gespräch mit mir und sagte mega picture
die sagte okay ich mache ein Foto von
dir er wünschte sich dass ich ein Foto
von ihm mache und dann hat er sich so
ein Pose gestellt ja das ist ein Tattoo
gezeigt und so weiter und so ein
halbstarker also so Lümmel den man gerne
mag ja und äh und dann sagte ich zu dem
während ich fotografiert habe erzähl mal
was was machst du ja geht zur Schule und
so und sagst du hier deine Eltern und so
wo sind die stellte sich raus seine
Mutter
arbeitet als Putzfrau in Griechenland
sein Vater arbeitet als Bauarbeiter in
Nordirland das heißt der ist allein ganz
allein und war damit seiner Freundin
unterwegs und so weiter das heißt auch
der ne also wer fängt den auf wer zeigt
dem sozusagen den Weg das war sehr
interessant und ich musste oft an weißt
wir haben über den ja häufiger
gesprochen Ivan krasse den bulgarischen
Politologen sprechen den wir beide sehr
schätzen du hast ihn ja schon getroffen
ja genau
tolle Sendung empfehle ich noch mal sehr
dein Gespräch mit die waren krasse eins
mit Sternchen und der spricht ja auch
ganz viel über diese demografische
Katastrophe die da in Osteuropa gerade
stattfindet richtig
Bulgarien ein Land das mal kurz davor
war zehn Millionen Land zu sein
mittlerweile reden wir über fünf ja das
geht alles immer weiter runter und
wollte
Rumänien es gilt für Moldawien es gilt
für Russland es gilt für die Ukraine
richtig alles über alternde
Gesellschaften genau die ihren Menschen
keine Zukunft anzubieten haben und wo
eben die hungrigen das Land verlassen
richtig und es ist auch wenn du junge
Leute dort sprichst also die Frage ob du
irgendwann dann Glück im sogenannten
Westen suchst die ich stellt sich
überhaupt nicht das ist
selbstverständlich brauchst du gar nicht
fragen ja völlig klar hier kann die
Zukunft wir gehen irgendwann weg und du
merkst das und das fand ich so so so
beeindruckend also diese Melancholie
oder Melancholie und die Stille in diese
diese Städte die wir so kennen diese
lauten vollen ja diese diese diese diese
vibrierenden Städte die manchmal auch so
anstrengend sind weil du nur im Stau
stehst und weil sie alle sich
gegenseitig auf den Füßen oben stehen
und weil er einfach irgendwann alle auf
den Keks gehen das gibt's doch nicht du
hast den Verkehr der 60er Jahre ja ja
genau ja und dann sind
sie ist die Stadt bunt von Werbung oder
ja es gibt schon so große große kleine
Tafeln ja ja genau
das gibt's alles in der Ukraine wir sind
danach über gereist nach nach Odessa in
der Ukraine das ist so das erste Zeichen
dass dir klar macht das ist an Land im
Krieg
diese großen Werbetafeln da sind nur
noch militärische Motive drauf
wo man sich bedankt bei den Soldaten und
so weiter das ist beklemmend das zu
sehen diese Checkpoints und so weiter
wenn du dann über diese Grenze
rüberkommst und dann auch interessant
ich ich hatte
wir haben gesehen da wird unglaublich
kontrolliert du stehst stundenlang an
diesem Grenzübergang Moldawien Ukraine
warum machen die das warum nehmen die
jedes einzelne Auto auseinander auch aus
der Ukraine heraus jedes einzelne Auto
wird genau unter die Lupe genommen und
so weiter
dieser Tage mit jemandem aus der
Berliner Politik gesprochen und sagte
sag man kann es sein dass hier Waffen im
großen Stil geschmuggelt werden und er
sagte das ist das Thema gerade überhaupt
auf politischer Ebene wir unterhalten
uns darüber wie wir den Waffen Schmuggel
aus der Ukraine heraus in den Griff
kriegen können das heißt ein Teil ein
sicherlich kleiner Teil aber ein Teil
der Waffen die der besten gerade in die
Ukraine liefert wird direkt stand der
pede wieder
herausgeschmuggelt das war übrigens von
Anfang an Thema also es gab immer wieder
Meldungen ne gleich zu Beginn der
Waffenlieferung das ja eben kein Land
ist dass man jetzt mit Deutschland
vergleichen kann sondern die die Ukraine
ist eben ein ausgesprochen korruptes
Land das auch völlig auf diesem
Korruptions Indizes ja genauso übel
abgeschlagen unten liegt die Russland
und das ist äh in der Tat natürlich ein
riesiges Problem
die Waffen wir liefern da Waffen hin und
dann Teil davon ja also
nicht nee mit Munition geht das zum
Beispiel
so was ja ganz genau ganz genau und ja
und dann da so reinzukommen und und
mitzukriegen was es wirklich bedeutet im
Krieg zu sein allein wenn du die mal
klar machst
es gab Flüge ne Direktflüge von Berlin
nach Odessa ich glaube eins 30 oder 1,45
knapp zwei Stunden dann warst du nur
besser heute von Hamburg aus auch von
Berlin aus nicht unter ich würde mal
sagen 14 15 Stunden zu erreichen keine
Chance
ich kann Direktflug mehr und allein was
das bedeutet sozusagen dieses dieses
drosseln von Geschwindigkeit im Bezug
auf Handelswege Handel treiben und so
weiter was das mit der Wirtschaftskraft
eines Landes macht natürlich bestehende
etablierte Lieferketten zerstört die
Logistik zerstört also es geht bei dem
was da gerade passiert ist ist mir da
noch mal so etwas eine griechischer
genau die dauerhaft bedeutet also es
gibt ja diesen diesen poetischen Satz
von Goethe Krieg Handel und Piraterie 3
einig sind sie nicht zu trennen richtig
also es ist ja der hat ein Krieg macht
ja ganz viel ein Krieg schafft neue
Schwarzmärkte wie wie hier für Waffen
ein ein Krieg hat die dubiosesten
kriegsgewinner und Trittbrettfahrer ja
ein Krieg äh zieht die übelste Form von
Geschäfte Machern an ein ein Krieg nagt
an der Moral eines Volkes ja wenn die
Sage von der Front irgendwann
zurückkommen und jeder dann irgendwann
jemanden kennt der Sohn verloren hat
dort und und und ich meine die wie die
Situation aussieht im Augenblick
gekommen ja die Nachrichten dass die
Ukraine dasselbe macht wie die Russen
also dass sie dass sie vor allen Dingen
kriminelle einziehen oder dass sie ganz
normale Bürger wegen relativ kleiner
Vergehen zu kriminellen Stempeln um sie
dann zur Armee schicken zu können das
zeigt ja in welchem Zustand also nicht
nur das natürlich die Nerven blank
liegen das ist ja auch völlig klar nach
anderthalb Jahren Krieg das einem die
Leute ausgehen aber was wiederum wird
aus einem Land wenn die Polizei und das
Militär zu solchen Mitteln greifen muss
um so die Soldaten zu richtig die
gleichen Prozesse werden wir mit
Sicherheit genauso in Russland haben
also das zerstört ja ganz ganz viel also
viel Vertrauen und und öffentliche
Ordnung die über lange Zeit gewachsen
sind und in diesen Ländern sowieso nicht
sind wie genau die werden der völlig
irodiert in solchen kriegst dass der
Punkt dass der Punkt weil du das gerade
sagst Richard Vertrauen gibt noch eine
zweite Sache wenn du in KIS hinauf auf
diesen Markt von dem ich dir gerade
erzählt habe ja wenn du dort unterwegs
bist
auch als deutsches Kamerateam bist du
zunächst mal sehr herzlich willkommen
aber du wirst misstrauisch beugt von
allen denkst du wirklich wieso sind die
Leute so misstrauisch fehlendes
Vertrauen
russische Propaganda das systematische
infiltrieren die das die Zersetzung
dieser Gesellschaft mitgenommen genau
wie das funktioniert genau
also du hast auf diesem Markt z.B du
gehst dann dahin und dann merkst Du
plötzlich du bist da nicht allein und
ich meine jetzt nicht die Marktfrauen
die da steht sondern du merkst plötzlich
du wirst von links von einem Typen mit
dem Handy gefilmt und auch da plötzlich
rechts jemand auf dann dann filmst du
zurück dann merkt er oh die haben mir
jetzt gesehen dann verschwindet er
wieder so eine Menge dann plötzlich auch
da wieder auf
und dann denkst du okay was ist das für
einer damit der die fragst du den den
Mann der der da hilft ja der
irgendein verantwortlicher sagt ja wir
passen ein bisschen auf Euch auf
ist natürlich der Geheimdienst ja so und
der Geheimdienst er arbeitet jetzt eng
mit den Russen zusammen oder nicht ist
man weiß nie so genau wer diese Leute
sind man weiß es nicht so genau aber
fakt ist du machst dort keinen Schritt
unbeobachtet und das Interessante ist
ich ich habe da ein paar mal gesagt was
worüber reden wir jetzt hier ist das FSB
ist das russische Geheimdienst
FSB sagt dort kein Mensch die sagen alle
Tage
immer noch absolut niemand redet vom FSB
alle reden vom KGB das jetzt so tief
drin das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen
dieses und und und auch da verstehst du
mal wieder was es bedeutet was ist mit
deiner Gesellschaft macht wenn man sich
gegenseitig einfach nicht vertrauen kann
wenn keiner dem anderen über den Weg
traut und das habe ich auch in der
Ukraine gemerkt auch da du denkst ja du
kommst dahin als Reporter Team und
willst eigentlich mal erklären was in
der Ukraine passiert bist du plötzlich
merkst die sind alle hellwach egal wo du
bist egal wo du eine Kamera rausholst an
der Ampel einmal raus fotografiert dann
kannst du die Uhr stellen wie lange es
dauert bis der Typ neben dir im Auto die
Scheibe runter macht und sagt wer seid
ihr was macht ihr dann sagt bist du
Polizist nein ich bin einfach nur ein
Mensch auf dem Weg zur Arbeit aber die
die die die sind wachsam die passen auf
ja voll weil sie genau weil sie Angst
haben du könntest irgendeinen russischer
Agent sein irgendeiner der sozusagen das
nächste Ziel ausspioniert das ist der
Punkt auch das ist natürlich für ein
Land im Krieg ne ganz gesteigert so ganz
klar aber das habe ich da das erste Mal
wirklich verstanden du bist den
Wohnblocks irgendwo unterwegs kommen
Leute raus wird sofort misstrauisch
beugt die Leute gucken wer sind die was
machen die da spionieren die Ziele aus
dann triffst du eine junge Frau vor
einem dieser Wohnblocks die dir dann
erzählt vor acht neun Monaten ist hier
in der russische Rakete eingeschlagen
sie war mit ihrem kleinen Kind da drin
ihr Mann war gerade nicht da und das
ganze Geschehen ist 89 vielleicht auch
zehn Monate her und sie fängt an von
diesem von diesem von dieser Nacht zu
erzählen und sie fängt sofort an zu
weinen das sieht so tief auch da ne
Vertrauen sozusagen einfach in den
Jahren
noch da also die Gewissheit dass du
nachts dass Du in Ruhe einschlafen
kannst und am nächsten Morgen wieder
unversehrt auf warst wenn diese
Gewissheit weg ist dann mach das was mit
so einer Gesellschaft und wie wir haben
es erlebt wir waren da und
dir der letzte Angriff auf Odessa war
relativ lange her
zwei Tage nach unserer Abreise haben sie
dann wieder angegriffen mit Drohnen und
mit Raketen die ganze Zeit dieser
Luftalarm die Leute hören gar nicht mehr
richtig hin aber alle passen auf alle
sind ständig irgendwie dabei gucken was
passiert was was läuft hier eigentlich
dieses zersetzen der Gesellschaft läuft
vor allen Dingen medial und dann ganz
konkret mit mit Leuten die dafür bezahlt
werden von russischer Seite Unruhe zu
stiften und es war war beeindruckend
wenn du mit mit Leuten redest in den
Tisch hinein molder auf der Straße dann
sagen die dir ja dieser Krieg ist
schlimm aber die russische Propaganda
ist in Wahrheit noch viel schlimmer und
wir sind dieser russischen Propaganda
seit Jahrzehnten ausgesetzt aber erzähl
noch mal der dass die russische
Propaganda läuft doch jetzt nicht über
das Staatsfernsehen doch die läuft die
läuft im Fernsehen erklär mir mal die
die Regierung ist doch pro westlich
möchte Mitglied der EU werden genau
senden doch jetzt keine russische
Propaganda im Fernsehen oder das ist
mittlerweile verboten Mayas andu heißt
die moldawische Präsidentin sehr
integere Frau
aber das ganze wird gesteuert
mittlerweile zum Teil im Internet und so
weiter Radiosender Fernsehsender gibt es
einen Oligarchen
Ilan Shore heißt der den sozusagen jeder
Mensch der große oppositionssmack so
ganz genau 'ne ganz obskurve Figur ganz
obskurve Figur der der ist mittlerweile
nach Israel geflohen und steuert von da
aus sein Medien Imperium der hat glaube
ich drei Mal dawische Banken um eine
Milliarde Euro betrogen und kann
trotzdem seine Fernsehprogramme da genau
aber das ist im Land geblieben weil er
in der Lage war die italienische Justiz
so zu manipulieren das funktioniert hat
für ihn ja also der hat drei drei Ruinen
getrieben und genau das rein nach wie
vor Fernsehsender genau die ganz normal
von der moldawischen Bevölkerung
kostenlos empfangen wird die werden
geguckt und und die Leute die Leute
werden von morgens bis abends mit
russischer Propaganda berieselt wenn du
willst ersten und dann gibt es am
Wochenende und wir haben das auch
gesehen gibt's dann so Demonstrationen
und dann wird dann noch genauer
verstehen es gibt ein Pro westliches
Fernsehen und ein Pro russisches
Fernsehen ja also diese diese diese
dieses russische Propaganda Fernsehen
sozusagen das das lange Zeit wirklich
auf allen Kanälen lief das ja dass das
hat man mittlerweile eingedämmt und das
machen die jetzt im Internet einfach so
weiter ach so das ist verboten worden
genau das ist verboten worden aber aber
die
ich sag mal so haben wir schon häufiger
darüber gesprochen ne im 21 Jahrhundert
ist es praktisch nicht mehr möglich
Medien wirklich zu zensieren ja ne also
wenn Leute
Informationen und das Volk bringen
wollen
großartige Möglichkeiten es war noch nie
so wunderbar wie heute ja Autokraten
haben was das angeht wirklich leichtes
Spiel ja genau grundsieger der
Digitalisierung so einer der großen
Sieger nicht der einzige aber ja genau
es ist der der der feuchte Traum von
Diktatoren und autokratischen da gerade
Ware so ist es und und du hast dann
zusätzlich immer diese diese diese
Demonstrationen am Wochenende ne da
werden dann Leute dafür bezahlt die
Wissen zum Teil noch nicht mal wogegen
sie da eigentlich gerade protestieren
und demonstrieren die kriegen dann 20 €
40,50 € sprechen teilweise auch Russisch
das sind sie groß sind diese Demos
unterschiedlich also die haben es
immerhin geschafft wirklich Großdemos
auf die Beine zu stellen mit 10.000 von
Menschen gegen
Rentenreform und so weiter und so fort
gegen die böse Inflation gegen die böse
NATO gegen diesen bösen Westen gegen die
bösen amerikan vor allen Dingen zu der
Amerikaner sind dort echt eine es ist
ein Reiz eine Reizwort wenn du Amerika
sagst aber nicht für alle sondern jetzt
sozusagen für den einen Teil der
Bevölkerung für den einen Teil ganz
genau und und die machen regelmäßig am
Wochenende Rabatts regelmäßig jetzt in
die versuchen wir das mal also ich finde
das mal verstehen
warum die jetzt was gegen Amerika haben
also man muss ja ehrlich sagen Moldawien
oder Moldau war uns ja bis vor einigen
Jahren völlig egal das einzige was ich
mich erinnern kann ist dass die
Nationalmannschaft mal da war daher
kenne ich überhaupt nur den Namen der
Hauptstadt noch ja genau
ist wenn da nicht Deutschland mal
vorgebracht geschätzt 10 15 Jahren
Qualifikationsspiele ausgetragen
deswegen gibt's aber wahrscheinlich auch
ein modernes Hotel in der Stadt nein
aber ansonsten war uns das ja völlig
egal jetzt ist dieses Land wahnsinnig
wichtig geworden
weil es um die Frage geht wird das
weiterhin irgendwie zu russischen
Einfluss wäre gehören oder wird es auch
in Zukunft Teil der westlichen
einflussfäre sein und wenn ich dich
richtig verstanden habe das ist das Land
in dieser Frage zutiefst gespalten genau
das ist der Kampf dieser Satz mal von
zutiefst gespalten richtig und
beide also die Russen machen da ihre
Propaganda ja gegen die Amerikaner und
auf der anderen Seite versucht die EU
und auch die USA immer einen größeren
Fuß oder ein Bein in die Tür dazu
kriegen genau das ist ja so ich meine im
auf dem NATO-Gipfel in Madrid 2022 hat
man beschlossen
Moldau militärisch zu unterstützen
richtig das ist insofern keine
Kleinigkeit als dass das Land
verfassungsmäßig zur Neutralität
verpflichtet ist was übrigens nicht auch
keine schlechte Idee ist also wenn man
auf der einen Seite
das imperialistische russland hat ja
dass ich immer weiter vom Besten in die
Engel getrieben fühlt und auf der
anderen Seite eben das Interesse der USA
die Russen auch tatsächlich in Linie zu
treiben und man selber ist davon
betroffener dann ist das Beste was einem
passieren kann wäre eine Neutralität
aber aus diesem Status ist das Land raus
richtig auf der einen Seite versuchen
die Russen es in ihren Machtbereich zu
ziehen mit der ganzen Propaganda von der
du erzählt hast richtig alle Ziehen und
Zerren daran und auf der anderen Seite
haben wir die Europäer die haben eine so
herrliche Institution die nennt sich
europäische Friedens faszinität
werde ich diesen Namen ausgedacht hat
dabei geht es um militärische
Unterstützung von nicht NATO Mitgliedern
mit europäischen Geld und wird
europäischen Waffen im Zweifelsfall auch
und man hat dann an Moldawien so genannt
ein nicht tödliches Hilfspaket nicht
tödliches hilfsverkehr also das sind ja
zynische Formulierung total ja geliefert
das heißt wir haben inzwischen
militärisch im Fuß in der Tür die USA
und die Europäer auch
und damit wird dieses Land zum Zankapfel
richtig und meine ganz üble Befürchtung
besteht darin dass dann irgendwann das
gleiche Schicksal kommt wie in der
Ukraine nur dass der Krieg hier kürzer
dauert weil das Land nun wirklich klein
ist ich glaube die haben 6000 Soldaten
also die sind als militärmarkt
an Waffen beinhaltet ja wahrscheinlich
Satelliten Aufklärung und alle alle
möglichen anderen Dinge im Interesse des
Westens richtig und wenn wir das weiter
betreiben dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die Russen
irgendwann nicht nur Propaganda machen
sondern tatsächlich da ein marschieren
weil sie dessen Krieg ist der leicht zu
gewinnen ist das wird ja immer größer
also man bräuchte doch dringend eine Art
Moldawien Gipfel oder moldauung Gipfel
dass ich die beiden da irgendwie stärker
zurückhalten sonst ist das doch die
Ankündigung einer totalen Katastrophe
europäische friedensfastilität das sind
in die Schule Begriff wie physische
Infrastruktur mag ich auch ja ist auch
hübsch wenn die EU eigentlich sagen will
wir bauen jetzt ganz toll ne e
verstärken physische Infrastruktur weil
das böse Wort Zaun nehmen wir natürlich
nicht in den Mund selbstverständlich
nicht ja und nicht nötig ist Hilfspaket
ist auch hübsch ist auch nicht schlecht
ja das ist alles unfassbar zynisch und
zwar von beiden Seiten das finde ich
auch glaube allerdings Richard und das
ist mir dort nämlich schon klar geworden
wir haben einen riesigen Fehler gemacht
damit meine ich wir als der Westen wir
auch als Deutschland wir eine riesigen
Fehler gemacht indem wir uns so sehr auf
die Russen konzentriert haben und
einfach den Rest von Osteuropa nicht
zugehört haben ich sag dem Beispiel
egal wen du in Moldawien fragst die
machen sich absolut keine Illusion
darüber mit wem sie es da zu tun haben
über die Gewalttätigkeit die
Bereitschaft zu ultimativen Gewalt der
Russen über die Frage was dir eigentlich
Vorhaben über die Frage ob die
möglicherweise die Idee im Kopf haben
Moldawien morgens zum Frühstück einfach
mal wegzunehmen mitzunehmen sich
einzufleiden da machen sie sich
überhaupt keine Vision darüber und das
hat zu tun mit 1992
transistrieren kannst nichts drin ist
ist ein wenn du willst ein russisches
Separatisten Gebiet ja in Moldau ja
ungefähr so groß wie Brandenburg der
lebt ungefähr eine halbe Million
Menschen in diesem Land spricht es
wirklich wieso wie so ein langer
Streifen und der grenzt direkt an die
Ukraine so wird dieser möchte gern Staat
wird nur anerkannt von uns Ländern wie
Süd Aussehen und abasien die ihrerseits
auch das Problem haben helfen keinem
anerkannt werden
ich erinnere mich dass Sheriff Tiras
Pohl Sheriff ist irgendwie so ein so ein
Unternehmen dem irgendwie das ganze Land
gehört Sheriff ist also der Sheriff
konzernt wir haben auch bei denen in
diesem Supermärkten eingekauft
waren ja also ich glaube die machen
alles Supermärkte Waffen alles Import
Export jeglicher Art
Fußballverein aufgerüstet richtig cool
und haben damit sogar Real Madrid Real
Madrid ja genau
wenn du irgendjemand danach fragst ist
die größte Heldentat in der Geschichte
von transferien einmal Real Madrid zum
Teufel geschickt zu haben richtig und
der zuständige
Oligarch ob es jetzt mal freundlich
auszudrücken ist Viktor gusan heißt er
ja der betreibt alles also wie du sagst
Import Export Tankstelle Supermärkte
Hotels eine eigene Destillerie dann
Fußballverein
Kaviar Brandy Textilien alles und alles
exportiert und kontrolliert und
gehandelt ist mafiastad ja und und
ehrlich gesagt auch ein großer Teil
davon da kommt wieder unsere berühmte
Scheinheiligkeit ins Spiel nach
Deutschland natürlich auch ne weil die
können günstig produzieren warum weil
Russland Ihnen kostenlos Energie gibt
die liefern
als Werkbank also unsere Firma als
Werkbank aber vor allem da wird
unfassbar geschmuggelt der Textilien der
Wette wird Waffen alles kommt da günstig
rein ja einfach so zollfrei Ware Import
Exporte aller Art und so weiter eine
Spur für z.B nach Wiesbaden und da
gibt's einen Mann namens Andreas reich
der mit Katina TV zu tun hat ja das ist
so ein Vordenker so ein machernes
Medienunternehmens und der hat unter
anderem er und seine Frau die kommen
ursprünglich aus transnistrieren der hat
beste Kontakte offensichtlich zu Viktor
gusan ja das ist der Kollege sprechen
dort nur bekannt unter dem Namen Sheriff
also du machst nur sagen und dann ist
alles klar die die Supermärkte heißen so
wir haben da auch eingekauft dann
kriegst du dieses Plastik Geld
nicht in altes transistisches Wort ne
sondern das meint wirklich diesen
Western Sheriff ja ja ja genau da gibt's
die Karl liebknecht-straße interessant
ist auch wenn du Leute fragst auch in
Berlin ich sag nur das ist wie ein
gefrorene Sowjetunion man hat ja gesagt
ja oft über transistian so eine Art
Jurassic Park das muss also zumindestens
ästhetisch ja also mittlerweile ist ja
eigentlich ein wild Weststadt ne mit
irgend so einem
Oligarchen als crackpot da also
Deluxe dass sich das Land unter Nagel
gerissen hat ja hammer und Sichel auf
den Flaggen und so weiter die raspohl
ist ja die Hauptstadt der der warm wird
drin und wurden dann auch das fand ich
interessant wie kam da rein und hatten
eine einen Reservierung in einem
Restaurant und wir wurden bereits
empfangen also die die wussten dass wir
kommen die wussten auch genau
das war spektakulär dachte wow der weiß
ja wirklich ganz genau Bescheid ja das
waren die Leute die dich vorher in
Moldawien da auf dem Markt ähm ja ja ja
der sagt das war so einer dieser Typen
eigentlich hier mache dir dein Angebot
und ja heute Mittagessen bei mir
persönlich kennengelernt ja ja der saß
der hat uns schon erwartet auf diesen
Scham den man so sehr ziehen kann ja
sehr nett und wir mussten danach
aufpassen wir sind da als als Touristen
rein wir haben da nicht gefilmt
wir sind als Touristen rein weil du
offiziell das Kamerateam da auch gar
nicht mehr reinkommt da riskierst du
auch dass du festgehalten wirst und so
weiter und allein dieser Grenzübergang
der der hat es wirklich in sich und dann
diese diese bröckelnden Platten Bauten
und dann hast Du natürlich den Lenin ja
der vor dem vor dem Parlament so eine
eigene Flagge ist dann gibt es den den
Obersten Sowjet noch da sozusagen ja
dann dann dann auf einem der Häuser
Blocks da gibt's dann so ein großes Bild
von Juri Gagarin ja der erste Mensch der
Sowjetunion und so weiter
sehr wir sehen der der ganze ausblock
sah mal so aus ne und ja das ist der
größte Teil 90% davon irgendwie
abgerissen genau und manche sogar 100%
richtig aber da ist das alles noch da
also das
Freilichtmuseum die wenn man so will es
ist ein historisches Freilichtmuseum ja
es ist so eingefrorene Sowjetunion und
und du spürst halt so diese diese ganze
Atmosphäre da wie das so ja du weißt nie
genau kommen wir wieder raus kommen wir
wieder rein wie läuft das eigentlich so
runter sind da sind halt dann seit 92 92
hab die Sowjetunion oder hat Russland
Moldau angegriffen und hat sich diesen
diesen Landstrich sozusagen einverleibt
ist eine dieser berühmten eingefrorenen
Konflikte ich meine
du hast Transnistrien schon aufgehört
und und darüber nachgedacht und so
weiter du kennst ja sogar gaga-usien ja
kann dich bis dahin nicht ähm das hört
man mal aufklären ne das sind die die
türkische stämmigen Bewohner moldaus im
Süden richtig genau ich sag dir gleich
was dazu nur transistrieren sehr
interessant für mich war transistrieren
immer ich wusste da gibt es die die
diese so so ja so ein eingefrorenen
Konflikt das ist alles schwierig da und
so weiter aber irgendwie kommt ein
Großteil auch der Energie für Moldawien
kam ursprünglich daher die haben auch
sehr viel Schwerindustrie da und so
weiter also das war war durchaus
strategisch gut überlegt sich genau
diesen Landstrich einzuverleiben und die
die
dieses transisting war für mich immer
etwas naja gut das kennt man so auch von
der Zeitungslektüre im kollektiven
Bewusstsein der moldawia ist
transistrierend absolut präsent dieses
92 ist für die der Punkt seitdem wissen
die ganz genau mit wem Sie es zu tun
haben und wie gefährlich die sind und
wozu die wirklich bereit sind und da
habe ich verstanden woher auch der Frust
der Osteuropäer mit uns teilweise kommt
was weil wir den nicht zugehört haben
wir wollten das nicht machen
wir sowieso nichts gemacht aber allein
es zu ignorieren und einfach die ganze
Zeit so zu tun als wäre das schon ganz
okay und solange mit den Russen ein
bisschen Handel treiben ist alles in
Ordnung die wussten ist besser aber wir
haben ihn nicht zugehört ja aber mal da
wir müssen erst kurz vorher unabhängig
geworden
zerfällt ja und einerseits sogar der der
gute Onkel Gorbatschow und auf der
anderen Seite jetzt sind versuchen an
der einen oder anderen Stelle an den
meisten hat man es ja nicht getan diesen
Vorfall aufzuhalten oder Zerfall
aufzuhalten
das hat man damals unter diesem
Gesichtspunkt gesehen mal gucken was am
Ende übrig bleibt also es war ja in der
damaligen Situation Anfang der 90er
Jahre nicht klar ob diese sich jetzt für
unabhängig erklärenden so wertrepubliken
ob die jetzt dauerhaft unabhängig
bleiben wollten würden oder was nachher
wenn es Kern Russland zurückgeholt wird
und was nicht also es wäre völlig
undenkbar gewesen dass der Westen damals
1992 ein riesen Fass aufgemacht hätte
wegen Moldawien das hat uns zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt überhaupt noch nicht
interessiert weil der Westen grenzte ja
noch gar nicht an Molda wichtig
dazwischen waren ja alles Länder wie
eben Rumänien und Bulgarien und so
weiter die alle ja überhaupt noch nicht
wieder zur NATO gehört noch zur EU
das war ja ganz weit weg aus der
damaligen Perspektive das stimmt und man
hätte auch gar nichts machen können also
insofern kann man nicht sagen wir haben
die damals im Stich gelassen soll man
die die waren damals völlig außerhalb
das war die erdabgewandte Seite des
Mondes
ich habe auch nicht gesagt im Stich
gelassen ich meine nur wir haben ihn
nicht zugehört und und tatsächlich ist
das glaube ich einer der großen Fehler
andererseits und deswegen fand ich halt
so so interessant wenn du diese Welt
eintauchst und plötzlich merkst niemand
redet vom FSB sondern es ist alles immer
noch Tage alles es ist immer KGB ja die
sehensucht nach der guten alten
Sowjetunion ja die Sehnsucht nach der
guten alten Zeit die so geil nicht wahr
ja wir haben es manchmal
überhaupt nicht wahr ja genau es war es
war früher nicht alles besser es war
einfach nur früher ja es war einfach
anders schlechter
genau
ja als heute es war auch eine andere
soziale Absicherung da wir heute genau
und auf der anderen Seite war die die
Bewegungsfreiheit noch viel
eingeschränkter als sie heute ist wobei
es ist immer die Frage früher hat der
Staat quasi die Entfaltungsmöglichkeiten
der Menschen eingedämmt und jetzt sind
es solche Leute wie der Freund der dich
damit Wodka bewirtet hat also man ist im
Grunde genommen vom Regen in die Jauche
gekommen es ist richtig ja wobei der
kavi aber wirklich
Kaviar ist da ein großes Thema habe ich
gemerkt du hast ich kaufen lassen
bezahlt wir haben da ganz normal
gegessen das war auch sehr nett ich
womit man ihn transistrieren die haben
eigenes Geld die haben so so viel Geld
wir haben auch ähm
ich musste leere Geschichte erzählen wir
ich wollte unbedingt ein bisschen Geld
aus transistrieren mitnehmen zu
Erinnerung weil du weißt ja nie genau
wie lang gibt's das noch ja die die
Münzen sind auch nicht aus Metall und
wirklich Plastik
und dann gibt es so Papiergeld und Lukas
der mitgereist ist hat das lukas ist
immer zuständig für dubiose Aktionen ja
und hat da hat dann dieses Geld
organisiert so wechseln lassen und so
weiter so und steckte das dann in mein
Pass einfach ums aufzubewahren und als
wir einen behandelt werden
auch eingereist sind in Moldau
eingereist sind kommen wir diese
Passkontrolle und ich reicht der diesen
Pass rüber der damalige da sitzt und
merkte plötzlich es gibt hier irgendein
Problem
und wenig später gingen wir raus und
dann öffnet sich die Tür aus einem Büro
Seitenflügel kommt ein Mann der
provozierend langsam auf uns zugeht und
sagt
hello
sagt okay gleich gibt's ja ein riesen
Problem und ich merkte schon okay der
hat das gelernt der hat's drauf und der
wird uns jetzt Angst machen und er sagt
er what's this wie ist die passport und
ich sagte wieso ist in einem normaler
deutscher Pass wo ist das Thema und er
so aber sie ist wie der passport und
sagte dann was ist das mit diesem
Passwort und sagt ja keine Ahnung wir
wollen hier einreisen wir arbeiten hier
wir haben eine Drehgenehmigung es ist
doch alles in bester Ordnung bis sie
raus stellte er hatte das transistische
Geld in diesem Pass entdeckt und hat
selbstverständlich dass als
Bestechungsversuch gewährt ja und wollte
sozusagen sagen Freunde also hier wird
nicht bestochen damit das klar ist ja
nimmt das Geld ballerts auf den Boden
und gibt uns den Pass zurück und sagt er
macht das nie nie wieder versucht nie
wieder mit Geld in einem Pass nach
Moldawien einzureisen das war
sensationell ich dachte wir kriegen
Ärger bei den transistrien waren das war
es aber nicht es war nur die Tatsache
dass ein paar Scheine in diesem Pass
waren er hat aber nicht angenommen er
hat sich angenommen es war ein ganz
wichtig klar zu machen was für ein
aufrechter Grenzbeamter ist aber was war
interessante auch so diese man nimmt ja
da merkst du halt immer wieder wie schön
es ist in einem in einem Land wie
Deutschland zu leben ich ja ich erlebe
deutsche Autoritäten Polizeibeamte
Grenzbeamte ja ich erlebt immer als
Menschen die die die soll man sagen die
die sind Demokraten ja die sind im
Dienste des Bürgers unterwegs
wird gesagt dass sie freundlich sein
soll ja richtig ich weiß nicht seit wann
das so ist vielleicht seit 20 Jahren bei
meiner Kindheit und Jugend war das noch
ein bisschen anders aber der Staat macht
eine Scham offen sive mit seinen Namen
das gibt es in sehr wenigen Ländern der
Welt in England gibt es das finde ich so
ja stimmt da war der Bobby schon immer
freundlich der Freund dein Freund und
Helfer ja richtig
ja okay so weit würde ich jetzt
vielleicht nicht gehen Scham Offensive
aber ich alle was du meinst
er Richard in jedem Fall
interessant ich musste noch eine Sache
erzählen das eine ist die die
Bereitschaft dieser dieser ukrainischen
Soldaten Irland zu verteidigen wir
hatten Gelegenheit
mit schwer Kriegsverletzten Soldaten zu
sprechen in einer und das war eine
wirklich
skurrile seltsame merkwürdige Situation
noch nie so eine Situation erlebt wir
waren in einer Schönheitsklinik die
machen Schönheitschirurgie und da werden
aber nicht nur Frauen behandelt die dort
sehr zahlreich nach wie vorhin kommen
also da finden schön als Operation am
laufenden Band statt mitnehmen
kriegt und man ist ohnehin überrascht
was mit dem Krieg alles ganz normal
weitergeht weil wir Menschen
offensichtlich so sind und ich glaube
das ist eine wie soll man sagen das ist
auch eine Stärke ist auch etwas was uns
ausmacht dass wir unglaublich in der
Lage sind uns anzupassen an Situationen
und das siehst Du daran dass das Leben
einfach weitergeht und so eben auch in
dieser Schönheitsklinik und du hast dann
die völlig absurde Situation gab so eine
Eingangshalle wir zeigen das auch in der
Reportage die wir dann am 18 mai senden
werden eine Eingangshalle
da laufen rechts diese Frau und links
sitzen Schwerverletzte Kriegsveteranen
Männer die gerade von der Front kommen
Männer ich habe mit einem gesprochen die
ganze Nase weggesprengt der hatte bis
vor kurz vor dem Krieg in Moskau auf
Baustellen gearbeitet und sagte das geht
jetzt nicht mehr ich kann nie wieder mit
Russen zusammenarbeiten dem haben sie
dort in dieser Klinik für plastische
Chirurgie einfach eine neue Nase
modelliert ein anderer hatte seinen
kompletten Unterkiefer einfach Ursprung
der Schönheitschirurg ich weiß der
Ursprung der Schönheitschirurgie ist ja
nicht Menschen aufzupimpen und zu
wichtig sondern kriegsversehrte und
Kriegs verletzte wieder ja zu stellen
richtig deswegen ist sicher mal ihren
Anfang wichtig der viel bessere Begriff
dafür absolut aber diese Situation war
halt so Pizza ich habe eine Szene im
Kopf das konnten wir nicht drehen wir
liefen da einen Schuh entlang und öffnet
sich rechts eine Tür kommt eine Frau
raus komplett bandagiert als kämen sie
gerade von der Front die Kamera gerade
vom OP-Tisch und hat sich einfach ihr
Gesicht nach straffen lassen und links
kam einer raus der kam gerade von der
Front und war operiert worden und hatte
eine auch ein komplett bandagiertes
Gesicht untertreffen sich plötzlich
diese zwei bandagierten Gesichter auf
diesem Flur und der Film Bilder geworden
ja und und und du siehst da ist dieser
eine Mann der an der Front kämpft
letzten Endes damit die Frau die da
rechts rauskommt ihr Leben eigentlich im
Wesentlichen so weiterleben kann wie
gehabt naja gut also ich meine
Schönheitschirurgie gibt's auch in
Diktaturen und zwar nicht zu knapp das
Land mit den meisten
schönheitschirurgien auf der Welt
chirurgischen Eingriffen weißt du was
das ist
warte lass mir ihre Hand Iran genau ja
und Russland dürfte auch ziemlich weit
oben nicht ich glaube das ist aber ich
verstehe schon also dieser Kontrast das
ist krass zwischen dem schönen im Leben
und dem schöner werden wollen und dem
anderen wo es ums Überleben geht richtig
ja also einmal uns ums schöner leben und
dem anderen muss überleben und das so
direkt aufeinander genau das kann nicht
mehr vorstellen dass es sicher sehr sehr
Gänsehaut ja weil das eine ist so
existenziell und das andere ist so
unfassbar trivial ne richtig das eine
überlebensnotwendig und das andere ist
völlig egal ja genau das ist wie
Napoleon sagt vom erbenen zum
Lächerlichen ist es nur ein kleiner
Schritt ja ja genau so vom vom
paketischen zum Lächerlichen und vom
existenziellen zum überflüssigen richtig
richtig
also Richard abschließend gesagt ich
mein Gedanke dazu ich also viel gelernt
bin sehr froh darüber dass es die
Möglichkeit gab dass jetzt mal zu
bereisen und dann noch
Fernsehzuschauern zu zeigen und ich war
einmal mehr
überrascht und beeindruckt davon wie
unvorstellbar vielfältig dieses Europa
ist ja also ein Land wie Moldawien am
Rande Europas wie wir kennen das alle
gar nicht es ist gerade mal mit zwei
Flugstunden drei vier Flugstunden je
nachdem wie du heißt kommst du dahin von
Wien aus anderthalb Stunden bist du da
und du wachst auf sozusagen in einer
völlig anderen Welt und das dann
plötzlich so ihre Konstrukte wie
transistrieren oder gagarusien ja das ja
türkisch geprägt ist und ein paar Leute
aber die die ganz stark pro russisch
auch sind und die sagen früher in der
Sowjetunion war alles besser unter
anderem die Zigaretten die waren so viel
billiger und so Material der so einfache
Dinge darum geht's damit kriegst du die
Leute die Zigaretten waren in russischen
Sowjet Zeiten waren die einfach so viel
günstiger und deswegen wollen wir die
gute alte Sowjetunion zurück das wirst
du auf der Straße und dann Erdogan der
da auch mitmischt ja weil das sozusagen
seine Leute sind und so weiter dann
haben wir ein orthodoxen Mönch getroffen
dort spielt auch eine große Rolle die
orthodoxe Kirche ne sehr gläubige
Menschen
interessant der sagte wenn bei mir junge
Menschen heiraten dann sage ich ihnen
eure Aufgabe ist es mindestens fünf
Kinder zu kriegen weil sonst sterben wir
aus aber wenn die alle ins Ausland gehen
weil es keine Entwicklungsperspektive
gibt
was was glaubst Du ist die die richtige
oder beste Zukunft ich meine Moldawien
lag ganz lange im Schatten der
Weltgeschichte ne und hat dann es war
wurde in diesem Schatten zu einem armen
Gemüsegarten jetzt passiert dass das
grelle Licht der Öffentlichkeit auf
Moldau fällt weil die Gefahr droht das
hier ein Stellvertreter Krieg wieder
zwischen russischen macht Interessen und
amerikanischen macht Interessen
stattfindet was empfiehlst du was
passieren soll damit in Moldau sich das
Schicksal der Ukraine nicht wiederholt
was sollte man tun
ich glaube der Weg ist schon
eingeschlagen die die Stimmung wenn du
mit Leuten so sprichst Menschen wollen
der Perspektive für sich Menschen wollen
frei sein und der Blick wendet sich ganz
automatisch und natürlich unter dem
Eindruck dessen was da gerade jetzt in
der Ukraine passiert ist nicht Richtung
Osten sondern natürlich Richtung Westen
aber du hast gesprochen von diesen von
diesen
oppositions Oligarchen ja ja und dessen
Einfluss und das richtige von
konservativen Leuten die und wenn es
auch nur um Zigaretten geht
also du hast von deinem tief gespalten
im Land gesprochen ja also selbst wenn
das Interesse Richtung Westen geht
gerade der Jugend also der Jugend die da
bleibt und die nicht weggehen ne weil
die andere Option ist ja du hast ja
gesagt relativ leicht wegzugehen
heißt es ja noch lange nicht dass sie
diese Option bekommen
sondern die würden die also wenn man
sich ruckartig und schnell nach Westen
wendet wenn man relativ schnell
EU-Mitglied würde wobei ich mir auch
immer die Frage stelle wenn wir schon
die Ukraine ja ein bettelarmes Kriegs
zerstört das Land in die EU aufnehmen
wollen und auch noch mit Moldawien das
nächste Armen aus Europa ist ja und das
bei dem Zustand in dem sich die
Europäische Union derzeit befindet
richtig richtig sowieso Angst hat dass
wir uns damit Heil los übernehmen und
dass ich die Stimmung dann innerhalb
Europas absolut gegen die Aufnahme
dieser Länder ohnehin wird also ob das
dazu kommt ist ja ohnehin noch mal die
Frage richtig und wenn das ruckartig und
schnell ginge oder gar keine NATO
Mitgliedschaft oder ähnliches winkt dann
muss man eben damit rechnen dass die
Kriegsgefahr eben auch enorm steigt
richtig hier können wir davon ausgehen
dass mal da werden sich nicht lange wird
wehren können
also diese eingeschlagene Weg dass ihr
heimlich ne ich hatte vorhin davon
gesprochen also die Europäer und die
Amerikaner aufrüsten und auf der anderen
Seite die Russen wahrscheinlich
transistrieren aufrüsten und ihren
Oligarchen dann in als Kriegs Herz so
Felde führen werden gegen molder oder
wie auch immer man sowas am Ende macht
und das alles zu verhindern müsste man
sich nicht die die UNO da rechtzeitig
irgendwie einschalten dann müsste es
nicht Verträge geben die eine eine
langwierige Neutralität militärische
Neutralität schreibt also irgendetwas
damit sich diese Großkatastrophe in der
Ukraine hier nicht noch mal wieder hin
und
ja ist wahrscheinlich hast du recht also
ich bin kein Politiker Richard aber was
was du dort siehst und das ist dann
schon etwas was an auch nachdenklich
macht wie unvorstellbar komplex und wie
unvorstellbar kompliziert Politik
mitunter sein kann und ich möchte nicht
derjenige sein der dort die die
Entscheidungen treffen muss weil ich
glaube es gibt kein eindeutiges richtig
und auch kein eindeutiges falsch
ja das also dass das eindeutige richtig
wäre das zu tun was vom Ende her gedacht
und langfristig gedacht für die Menschen
immer da werden das Beste ist richtig
und nicht was den kurzfristigen
Interessen andere dient aber ich fürchte
dass die anderen viel stärkere Mittel
haben ihre Interessen durchzusetzen und
dass ich am Ende für die Menschen immer
da bin dann doch keiner interessiert das
ist meine große Befürchtung ja ist das
eine und der andere Punkt ist wie
machtvoll diese Werkzeuge der Propaganda
mittlerweile sind im 21 Jahrhundert also
du du liebst das und du denkst weißt du
was schaltest einfach alles ab weil was
du siehst ist die Leute werden
systematisch wirklich wuschig gemacht
die verstehen nicht mehr wo links und
rechts wo richtig und falsch wo oben und
unten ist sie wenn einfach nur noch
konfus und das ist so furchtbar und ich
denke immer irgendwann werden wir auch
als Gesellschaft ist ja auch ein Thema
dass wir selber ja auch längst haben
sie werden auf diese Dinge werden wir
irgendwann eine Antwort geben müssen ich
weiß noch nicht welcher aber wir werden
eine Lösung finden müssen nur so geht es
nicht weiter
also die die großgefahren die die
Digitalisierung mit sich bringt auf dem
Informationssektor
psychologischer Natur
politischer Natur
gesellschaftlicher Natur ich glaube die
werden immer noch alles im allem obwohl
wir häufiger Bedrohungsszenarien genannt
werden unterschätzt ja ich glaube dass
diese digitale Gesellschaft einfach eine
ganz andere Gesellschaft ist als die
Gesellschaften die wir vorher kannten
richtig und wir sind überhaupt noch
nicht trainiert oder gewohnt werden
weder im juristischen die richtigen
Schritte zu machen noch in unseren
normalen Verhaltensweisen die wir
tagtäglich machen darauf angemessen zu
reagieren die technische Entwicklung ist
einfach viel viel schneller als die
Gesellschaft überfordert uns als
Menschen dass der Punkte darüber reden
wir noch mal ganz ausführlich sehr gerne
ja Richard viel gelernt ja danke dir und
ähm 18
war aber vielleicht irgendwann mal sein
werden zusammen nach transistriert ich
gerne mal mit dir also alles Liebe dir
danke danke tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pot
Stars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]